good evening everybody
welcome to Olsen's books and records
I've always you know Toni saying records
welcome to Olsen's books and records
when we don't sell records anymore we
sell CDs I've always wondered where the
term Ponzi scheme came from so when the
advanced readers copy of the book
written by tonight's guest came into the
store I snatched it up immediately I was
drawn into the tales of Charles Ponzi an
irresistible scoundrel who made and lost
a lot of money in the early 20th century
and established himself as a as a
financial legend please welcome the
professor of journalism and
award-winning author Mitchell Zhukov our
guest tonight I have one more request
when you want to ask a question would
you please go to the microphone over
there because we're being filmed thank
you for coming out on such an ugly night
I appreciate it
one thing I want to clear up really
instantly
some people seem to think that I bear a
certain resemblance to the man on the
cover of my book
I'd like to dispute that I am not
related or in any other way connected
beyond the the pages just to make sure
we're clear what I'd like to do is is
really talk more than read I'll read a
short passage but I really want to tell
you a bit of the story without giving it
all away first I want to make sure we're
all on the same page most people know
what a Ponzi scheme is or many people
know but I just want to be sure a Ponzi
scheme is not a pyramid scheme
they're both financial frauds but they
often get conflated into one thing and
in fact there are two separate kinds of
financial frauds a pyramid scheme is
built on the idea of a network there's
somebody at the top of the network and
often using a product or a promise
recruits ten people for instance
those ten people recruit ten people
always feeding the money up towards the
top of the pyramid I need to layer the
pyramid takes a piece of the pie as it's
going up toward the the top rung now
that kind of financial scam fails simply
because there aren't enough people
ultimately by the time you get down to
about the tenth level this it would need
10 billion people to satisfy all those
others above if you're doing a ten
tenten pyramid a Ponzi scheme is well it
used to be called robbing Peter to pay
Paul it was it's built on the idea of
early investors being paid their returns
out of the proceeds of later investors
investments so it's basically one guy in
the middle taking money from one hand
putting it in the other putting a little
bit in his pocket and then putting a
little bit out the other way so it's
similar they both are ultimately frauds
but what's most interesting to me as I
think about Ponzi and as I started to
research Ponzi is he never set out to do
this the thing he is remembered for the
thing that he is ultimately this scheme
that was named after him is not at all
what he intended he would had a
legitimate idea in mind he was sure it
was both legal and possible he was right
on one count it was legal where he got
into trouble was when he found out it
wasn't possible hold that off for a
second hold that in your minds for a
moment as we sort of moved through the
idea of a Ponzi and his scheme to
understand Ponzi and his scheme you
really have to start in the 1920s you
have to start by understanding the 1920s
and and what was happening at the time
the Great War is over immigration has
you know bolstered the population of
this country tremendously for the first
time there are more people living in
cities than there are out in the rural
parts of this country we also have a lot
of cultural forces at work at the same
time for instance women are getting the
right to vote but we are losing the
right to drink alcohol the start of
prohibition
19:20 and at the same time different
cultural forces are creating other
complications such as the Red Scare now
the influx of immigrants has led to an
enormous amount of fear among the
populace that anarchists have invaded
our shores and so they're rounding up
people simply because they are from
other places without any evidence
whatsoever at the same time we are what
we're experiencing is more than ever a
focus on money the old ethos the old
American ethos was a penny saved is a
penny earned
well that's positively colonial at this
point now the ethos is I want as much
money as I can get and the quicker the
better that was very much a theme and
you could read it in the newspapers any
time somebody made it rich he or she was
instantly put on the front page of the
newspaper it was a time when Richmond's
sports like golf or yachting suddenly
became front-page news so something was
changing in the in the culture that was
really affecting how people were looking
at themselves and looking at the world
around them now into this world steps my
man Charles Ponzi he was an Italian
immigrant he came here he actually was
born in 1882 in northern Italy he was
the child of a family that had once been
part of the aristocracy in Italy all of
his parents his mother's side of her
family carried the honorific don or
Donna before their name which linked
them to the Italian aristocracy but the
money was gone by the time Charles was
born Carlo as he was known then was born
but his mother made it clear to him that
she hoped that he her darling son would
restore the family to its past glory
that she would return he would return
the family to its great riches to its
great wealth and he spent his childhood
having her spin what he called castles
in the air and he knew what his role was
but he wasn't quite ready to accept it
for
he goes off to college at the University
of Rome and promptly falls in with a
group of aristocrats who like the
nightlife like gambling like picking up
the check and he was one of them
although he didn't have the resources to
really be one he had a small inheritance
it was supposed to pay his way through
college and instead he squandered it and
three years in he flunked out and washed
out with no money he goes back home and
they say Charles Carlo you have all
these young men from southern Italy
going to America coming back rich
certainly with your money with your
intelligence with your intellect with
whatever training you have had here in
college certainly you of all people will
prosper
by doing this so go come back rich he
goes to America lands in Boston and has
no luck for years he bounces up and down
the East Coast
working menial jobs and from one place
to another it seems like he is just
beset by failures or inopportune moments
now in 1907 he goes up to Montreal and
there he goes to work for a bank
and he's very is dapper he always
dresses well even despite his poverty in
America and he's articulate and he's
charming and he's got a thousand watt
smile and so he walks into a bank he
speaks at this point English French and
Italian and they hire him and there he
witnesses for the first time robbing
Peter to pay Paul the owner of the bank
Louisa Rossi was doing that very thing
to his own depositors Ponzi was not a
participant but as things fell apart
Ponzi wanted a little bit of traveling
money to get away and he made the
terrible mistake of forging a check for
$400 from one of the bank's accounts and
he takes that money buy some clothes
gets ready to leave for the United
States and he's quickly caught and
imprisoned for two years in Montreal
immediately upon his release he still
has no money he decides to go back to
the United States
and as he's crossing as he's about to
cross over the border he meat runs into
a man he knows who says if you will take
these other Italian immigrants back over
with you it will be something in it for
you
Ponzi sees an opportunity he takes it
instantly arrested again this time for
smuggling immigrants he's the only one
who speaks English so when the
immigration officials try to interview
him about these you know these men all
the other men can't speak any English
they let them go Charles Ponzi back to
prison this time in Atlanta for two more
years but throughout this process he
never loses this irrepressible optimism
this savoir faire this sort of the charm
of the bon vivant and he goes off in on
two more adventures and one thing I
found really fascinating that I loved
finding out was something that happened
after his second prison term a lot of
men might be bitter he has not come to a
he's not amounted to anything in this
great effort to make himself somebody in
America and he goes to a mining camp and
he comes up with an idea he's going to
start a utility for the mining camp he's
going to provide the mining camp with
water and power supplied and he's going
to sell stock and it's actually quite an
ingenious idea well he's working in the
meantime as a male nurse and one night
the doctor from the camp comes in and is
talking to Charles at this point now
he's known as Charles not Carlo anymore
and says I'm terribly upset have you
heard about pearl Gossett and Charles
had not and what happened was another
nurse in the camp pearl Gossett had been
burned horribly in a kerosene explosion
and she was at risk of death she was
certainly at risk of losing an arm and
Charles said why can't you help her and
the doctor said well I'd need somebody
to donate skin and nobody in the camp
will transplant II did not know this
woman except maybe peripherally he said
well how much skin do you need and
doctor said well quite a lot and Ponzi
said take all you need
he submitted himself to two major
operations in which they took 122 square
inches of skin from his back and from
the back of his legs to save the life of
this woman it was incredibly painful it
was incredibly heroic and it saved her
life now he suffered horribly he had
pleurisy he had all kinds of horrible
results I mean this is a time when
anesthesia was not a lot more advanced
than biting a bullet while he was
convalescing someone else came along and
did the utility so he lost out on that
opportunity too so once he finally got
out of the hospital the town hailed him
as a hero they put him up for a national
award from the Carnegie from the
Carnegie's but the next thing he knew he
had nowhere to go
he had still had no money and so he was
back on the road he continues traveling
around ends up back in Boston and there
his desire to become rich grows even
more intense now the reason is simple he
meets a woman and it's not roses fault I
promise you it's she is not the reason
why he got into trouble later in life
but he said over and over again
everything I did I did for rose and he
said that credibly because he truly and
deeply loved Rose connect oh this
daughter of Italian American immigrants
whose family owned a small fruit stand
in in Faneuil Hall in downtown Boston
and he wanted her draped in diamonds and
layered in furs he wanted to give her a
huge house and give her everything she
could possibly wish for now
the tragedy of this is that all Rose
wanted was Ponzi she loved him deeply
she wanted to have his children she
wanted a little house with a picket
fence she wanted him home for dinner
is basically what she wanted but that
wasn't enough for him he wanted her to
have every
well he keeps working in this store in
this import-export company called jr.
pool company but then decides he's got
to strike out on his own
her her family's Fruit Company is
failing so what he does is he takes it
over and tries to turn it around and
forgive me but it was fruitless I'm
sorry
it failed and so he said well I'm not
going back to work for somebody else
this is my moment to stake my claim so
he takes a small office in downtown
Boston on School Street and he starts
spinning more ideas spinning ideas that
will make him rich and some are
incredibly ingenious but none of panning
out he starts writing to people he knows
in Europe looking for opportunities and
then one day in the summer of 1919 one
writes back to him and with the letter
he encloses a strange little certificate
he encloses something called an
international reply coupon and IRC in
this little coupon it's a little flimsy
four by four inch piece of currency if
you will is basically one of the rare
forms of international currency and what
it does is it entitles the bearer to buy
a stamp in any country in the world and
they still exist today they're very
rarely in use but here's what they were
used for back then if you came there was
a lot of immigration as I mentioned if
you came from the old country here to
Boston and you wrote your mother a
letter in Italy you would enclose one of
these IRCs and you as a way to allow her
to buy a stamp to write you back now you
could put in a dollar but by the time
you know it's making it hard on her she
would have to turn that dollar into lira
and then go to the post office it was a
polite way in business or in personal
dealings to send a self-addressed
stamped envelope in effect
well Ponzi realized in all of his
schemes you want to call it scheming I
try to avoid that word and all of his
thinking about getting rich he was aware
that there was a tremendous
change in the value of currencies after
World War one currencies in Europe were
deeply depressed and almost immediately
he realized that this little coupon with
his it's fixed value no matter where it
was used in the world could be purchased
cheaply in European countries with
through their depressed currencies and
he could buy them in bulk on the cheap
there and if he could figure out a way
to get them here and trance transfer
them into cash he could make and this
was true profits of perhaps 500 or more
percent he tried it he wrote to a couple
of these friends in places with
depressed currencies and found that it
was true he enclosed the dollar had them
turned their into their native countries
currency buy as many of these as you can
send them to me and he found in fact it
was true he could buy five or seven
times as many with the same dollar in
some of these other countries Wow this
was like a bolt of lightning for Ponzi
he was sure he could get rich from this
legitimately and in fact if you go to
Wall Street today you have people doing
something very similar currency exchange
folks arbitrage this is what this was a
primitive form of what those people are
doing today all he needed all he needed
was a stake he needed money to get money
he had no money you know he was barely
paying the rent 227 school Street this
small office he was renting and so he
said okay let me go to the banks and
I'll try to borrow money he went to the
Hanover trust company and the the
president of the Bank Henry Shain
molinsky basically school escorted him
to the door he Ponzi had a small deposit
account and sure molinsky said your
deposits are more trouble than they're
worth we just you were not going to loan
you any money he had no track record he
had no resources he was an Italian
American immigrant with an Italian
immigrant still he had not become a
citizen with nothing to show for himself
so he decided my only pasta
my only opportunity is to go to the
public I'm going to basically turn
myself into a stock company I'm going to
raise money from other folks like me who
want to get rich who want a piece of the
American Dream and so he started slowly
offering investments and what it was was
a promise he told them I have a way to
get rich quick all you have to do is
give me any sum of money I promise I
will turn that back to you in first 90
then he actually shortened it to 45 days
with 50 percent interest this is at a
time when banks are paying 5% a year
even better than they are today but you
can have 5% a year or you can basically
double your money in 3 months now Ponzi
recognized Ponzi was a very savvy guy he
understood the laws of human nature and
it was simple then there are two sides
sides of human nature I think when it
comes to money on one side you have it's
too good to be true
that's the angel on this shoulder saying
don't don't don't do that you know that
it can't be possible how can he possibly
double your money in 3 months but on
this shoulder the devil on the other
shoulder is saying wait a second this is
too good to miss and all it takes
sometimes is the right salesman and
Ponzi was a soft sell he would never
pressure anyone to invest with him he
would just tell them this is what I'm
offering I have a way of turning IRCs
into money from one place to the other
but if you don't want to invest that's
fine
it was just enough to tip the scales
over to the devil on that other shoulder
and people came running now the first
month they eighteen of them gave him
$1,800 and they waited to see what would
happen and when Ponzi offered them their
money back from the people who followed
the next month word spread like wildfire
January 1920 he takes in about eighteen
hundred dollars by March of 1920 he
takes in 25
and dollars by June he takes in 2.5
million dollars back at a time when 2.5
million dollars was a lot of money in
July of 1920 it starts at a million
dollars a week and rising and near the
end of July 1920 he's approaching a
million dollars a day
he's got branches from Maine to New
Jersey and there are people across the
country clamoring for him to take their
money and give him their promise to give
them the promised return well what does
Ponzi do he fulfills his dreams he buys
a huge house in Lexington Massachusetts
near the start of the American
Revolution he buys himself a locomobile
finest car of its age it's a car with
sterling silver bud Voss's in the back
and a an AM an intercom that he can use
to tell his chauffeur who's sitting only
five feet away from him where to turn if
he has to go to the bank and he also
does something remarkable the whole idea
of a get-rich-quick scheme usually or
especially a fraud and this really
reveals something else about Ponzi just
like the story I told you about the skin
is there's an end-run part of the scheme
there's take the money and run normally
there was no an run in Ponzi's plan
Ponzi at the end of June 1920 was
walking around with a cheque certificate
of deposit made out to him for 1.5
million dollars in one pocket he
basically had a million and a half
dollars in his name in cash and in the
other pocket he had two first-class
tickets for himself and for rose to take
a long delayed honeymoon to Italy he
could have been gone at that moment we
never would have seen Ponzi again but he
knew that he wanted to go legit now at
this point he had not yet figured out
how to do the coupons to cash
transaction he had tried and tried and
never quite figured out how to make it
work so he started to use the old rob
Peter to pay Paul to buy himself some
I'm to just keep it going long enough
until he figured out another brilliant
idea that would get him out of this
enormous debt he was basically building
up because every dollar he took in he
essentially went into debt another 50
cents so he said I just need a little
more time now instead of running he took
those two tickets and instead brought
them to the ticket office and got two
other first-class tickets for his mother
and her nursemaid he brought his mother
who was at this point in her 70s Imelda
Ponzi the woman who had taught him that
he was going to be the one who made her
family rich again here to America he set
her up in their house in Lexington and
treated her like a queen and Andros was
delighted and it was a great it was the
greatest thing that ever happened to him
it was a happiest day he had had in 17
years since coming to America because
his wife and his mother were together
there he was not going to run
he might not figure it out but he was
going to try now in the meantime he also
bought some other things he bought the
Hanover Trust Company the bank that had
turned him down for his loan when he
first started just so he could become
the boss of Henry Shain Malinsky he
bought a macaroni company he bought
other firms
he bought a piece of a wine company he
just he wanted to turn this money into
some kind of legitimate business and in
the meantime he wanted to enjoy himself
well into this world steps
Richard grosser Richard grosser was the
son of the editor and owner of one of
the best newspapers of its day the
Boston Post
now Richard grower had a lot in common
with Ponzi he was a bon vivant a dapper
charming guy who had done everything he
could to flunk out of Harvard just as
Ponzi was trying to flunk out of
University of Rome
Richard was trying to flunk out of
Harvard well Richard had one advantage
one huge advantage his father was the
editor owner of the Boston Post and so
every time the Dons and the deans of
Harvard would try to throw
shirt out and put him to work Edwin
grows you would write another letter
which I was able to obtain during my
research saying please give Richard one
more chance and it would of course
always be on Boston Post stationery in
case they didn't get the message
and they always got the message and they
gave him one more and one more and one
more chance and he made it through
Harvard and then he graduates and spends
the next 10 years basically doing what a
lot of I guess the children of something
I shouldn't say a lot children of some
wealthy people do they sort of work for
the family business waiting for a chance
to prove themselves well in June in
March of 1920 his father suffers a
horrible stroke he had been had a huge
battle royale with the famous mayor of
Boston James Michael Curley
and the paper fell into the hands of
Richard grosser and Richard grosser
decides I want to make my mark and I
keep hearing about this guy Ponzi now
the newspapers had completely ignored
Ponzi there was the only media in town
was newspapers over seven or so great
newspapers but none were willing to
write about Ponzi either they weren't
aware of what he was doing or more
likely they were afraid to go after him
because if in fact he was doing what
they said what he said he was doing and
they accused him otherwise he would
almost certainly end up owning their
presses he would sue them and win but
Richard grosser basically bet the bank
bet his own inheritance and he went
after Ponzi and the first story appeared
on July 24th 1920 and he'll indulge
amount to read a short passage from that
moment the day that that story appears
in the front page of the Boston Post
the huge blue car moved slowly through
the crooked streets of the old city its
owner sitting on the wide rear seat his
bottom comforted by deep horse hair
filled cushions that absorbed the bumps
from the uneven cobblestones heat and
sunlight bounced off the brick and
granite buildings baking the locomobile
limousine and broiling its passengers
the morning air bristled with a hint of
a developing thunderstorm when the skies
broke loose it would be a welcome relief
from the weeks of summer heat that had
made downtown Boston ripe with the
smells of horses fish fruit fresh cut
leather and tight wound rope all
seasoned by salt from the nearby harbor
at the wheel of the hand polished
locomobile was a young Irish immigrant
named John Collins wearing the hat and
brass buttoned uniform of a newly
created job motorcar chauffeur his boss
an Italian immigrant had taken delivery
of the dazzling vehicle only three weeks
earlier paying $1,000 in cash above the
$12,600 list price too spirited away
from the New York financier for whom it
had been custom-built for the same price
a man could own 20 Model T's with enough
change to buy a modest house but what
was the point of that in 1920 the
locomobile was the most expensive car in
America dripping with luxury from
sterling silver trim to its crystal bud
Voss's in the short time he had been
driving the car Collins had learned well
the daily 12-mile route that began his
bosses gracious home in the historic
suburb of Lexington from there they
rolled east through working-class
Arlington and Summerville into Tony
Cambridge across the Charles River then
down Chairman Street - a nondescript
building on School Street less than a
block from Boston City Hall
occasionally there would be detours most
often to a bank and the boss would use
the one-way intercom from the backseat
to relay the new directions to Collins
but on this day July 24th 1920 it was
straight from home to office Collins
slowed as he turned down school Street
and saw what awaited them
a mob of several hundred men and women
crowded together hip to hip chest to
back viewed from above it looked like an
abstract mosaic of straw boaters and
colorful felt clothes
punctuated by the dark crowns of the
occasional boughs boat the occasional
bowler some in the throng had brought
bewildered children who cried or whined
as they struggled to avoid being
trampled underfoot the street was alive
with electricity unrelated to the
gathering thunderclouds it came from the
Horde itself the street normally would
have been all but deserted on a sultry
Saturday in late July but this was no
ordinary day when the crowd saw the
limousine turned down the street they
pressed toward it half in reverence and
half and mindless desire they parted to
allow Collins to steer toward the curb
in front of the Niles building a
twenty-seven school street the modest
home of his boss's extravagantly
immodest firm the impressively named
securities exchange company from his
perch in the backseat Collins's boss
could see that some men in the street
were holding copies of the Boston Post
the banner headline trumpeted a victory
of one of the America's Cup races by the
American yacht resolute over its British
challenger shamrock four at a time when
anything seemed possible except a legal
drink of whiskey elite sports like
yachting and golf had captured the
public imagination
if one subject interested Bostonians
more than risk rich men's sports it was
the prospect of becoming rich themselves
undeniable evidence was could be found
in that morning's post just below the
yacht race story on the left side of the
front page in bold black letters was the
headline that had filled School Street
to bursting doubles the money within
three months a post reporter had visited
27 school street a day earlier and
acquired a basic understanding of how
the SEC acclaimed to create spectacular
profits for its investors the unbalanced
story even described the locomobile
limousine in the boss's Lexington home
which was quote furnished with the best
and quote does not give the impression
of nouveau riche either for the fine
Italian tastes of the owner fixed that
the man who owned the fine home the
flashy car the securities exchange
company the adoration of the people on
School Street and anything else he cared
to buy was named Charles Ponzi
well in the wake of that story
another battle royale was precipitated
between Ponzi and the Boston Post and
only one could survive and literally it
was a test over the next few weeks in
the summer of 1920 as to which would
prosper and which would fail and into
that fray stepped all kinds of
prosecutors and investigators and
fellows like Clarence Baron the pheno
barons financial the greatest financial
journalist of his age came on to the
side of the post to help them find out
what this fault this ponzi fellow was up
to and I'm going to stop right there and
let you find out what happens I hope you
do and I hope you enjoy it thank you
thank you very much if any of you have
questions uh they I think they've asked
that you address them to the microphone
yes would you mind thank you
uh you did this rather quickly when he
was in Montreal he worked for somebody
named Ross as ROC zeal aussi
yes and zu Rossi was engaged in a
similar Peter to pay Paul type of scheme
yes and so was that the inspiration for
Ponzi never admitted that but yes we do
believe so that this was the first time
Ponzi had seen it and it what ended up
happening was too close to what we found
what I found at the surah C Bank to
overlook it it was certainly an
inspiration and uh you indicated that he
never found a way to convert these uh
postage coupons into cash correct
exactly he tried again and again and
realized that it was just simply the
logistics were impossible the first
eighteen investors who came in in
January of 1920 it would they're
seventeen hundred dollars in investments
it would have taken fifty three thousand
of these postal coupons just to pay them
off if he had turned them into cash and
I calculated that he would have filled a
huge steamer trunk just with those by
the time he had ten or fifteen or twenty
thousand investors as he did as adding
up millions of dollars I mean he would
have had to fill Titanic size ships with
these things and they simply didn't
exist there were no people at all even
before the the eighteen who put up $100
each who were able to get redeemed value
in dollars oh well that's a good
question in fact on the way many did
redeem their dollars there were a number
of these forty-five day periods did pass
and they did redeem their money for the
fifty percent interest but most didn't
put their money back in their pocket
they were so thrilled that it really was
true they might start with a hundred
dollars and risk that and when forty
five days came and they got 150 back
they said hmm in 45 days I'll have two
hundred and twenty-five dollars so they
took another spin on the carousel so
often they were just reinvesting and
reinvesting and Ponzi found the more he
gave the more he offered to give out the
more in fact came back
one side it certainly was a one-sided
Iver tried anyone else sure unless
something else uh the Ponzi scheme has
been replicated many times over and
that's one of the reasons I'm here
because we saw it in Enron we saw it
with the rei t's back over a generation
ago when they were in the construction
loan business and all they were doing
was accruing interest in paying
dividends on that exactly this is a
scheme that you know people sometimes
people have said to me
well today we're too sophistica no one
would fall for this well in fact every
day a new Ponzi scheme is dreamed up and
and yes
ITER I turned to Kurt I can wall the
expert on Enron whose new book wonderful
new book conspiracy of fools tells that
story and Kurt calls it a Ponzi scheme
Enron so they just take different forms
and my dad is a retired history teacher
from New York City and his Retirement
Board sent him a few months ago a
warning to all different retirees in
their system about the ten financial
frauds to watch out for and number one
on the list the Ponzi scheme so they're
still they're still with us yes hi your
last book was about a husband and a wife
who had a young child who endured
various medical hardships around Down
syndrome and so those were living
breathing people that you could go spend
time with you were at the hospital with
them in their homes with their in-laws
and yet with this book it's more dealing
with history and people who have been
long gone how did you cross that
rubicon if you will say and and bring
them as alive in this book as you did
with your earlier book could you explain
to us some of your research methods and
where you found the material to to bring
your story off the page as you so
wonderfully done thank you thank you for
that question I'm I'm I'm very proud of
the research that was almost in a way
the most fun part because it was
crossing a Rubicon for me I was a
reporter for the Boston Globe for 13
years and used to dealing with live
sources and if I wasn't sure of a fact
you could just call the person back and
say was it raining that day was it you
know well weren't you wearing blue if I
want to bring the narrative to life and
this was a whole other kettle of fish
and so the first thing I did was I being
a newspaper man at heart was I went into
the the basement of the Boston Public
Library and almost didn't emerge for 3
months
bringing up every story from every
Boston newspaper and then New York
newspapers and others that have been
written about Ponzi and found that the
newspaper men and women of the day had
done a wonderful job of capturing the
people the events what they were wearing
what they were thinking and then from
there it was really the pebble in the
pond from there I started going further
in following the leads that they that
those newspaper people was often on
byline stories had led me to and I
earned two judicial archives of the
court cases that ensued after this
didn't work out the way Ponzi had hoped
it would I turned to other archives the
National Archives had some wonderful
materials about the aftermath and then
on only then that I turned to Ponzi
himself he had an unpublished
autobiography that was in the Library of
Congress waiting waiting for me and and
then I could take that autobiography
and use his unique impressions of things
and test them against what the newspaper
people had found and then the other
people had found and then how it played
out in the court case and then finally
and most wonderfully even more wonderful
as that wonderful as the autobiography
was all those other materials gave us
the public poncey the ponzi that he put
his face out to the public when you
write a memoir an autobiography your you
know your this is how you want to be
seen or remembered his wife's family
they never had children Rosen Ponzi but
she was a devoted aunt through the rest
of her life to a number of nieces and
nephews they had saved a stack this
thick of all the letters that Ponzi had
written to her over their entire true
love affair and incredibly and I'm
grateful forever to the Gannett Co
family they shared them with me and
there I got to see the private Ponzi
because the letters you write to your
your beloved are different than the
autobiography you write to the world and
so right up to the very end of his life
these letters were an amazing record of
who he was and what was inside this this
man who was happy to show a different
face to the world thank you
I have a slightly different question one
of the things that you mentioned is in
the book is the amount of sort of media
competition that there was in Boston at
the time the number of newspapers they
were actively going after stories and
the risk that rich grocer took in
following this story do you see anything
about that that environment and and in
the in the media business at that time
to compare to now and do you draw any
lessons about you know the vigor of
investigative journalism and financial
journalism in particular sort of
following a story if you would
characterize this as a financial story I
don't know maybe you characterize it as
a different Enterprise for Richard
grosser but do you have any observations
on that thank you that's a great
question this is where I put on my hat
as professor of journalism and I get to
do that and I appreciate that there are
absolutely parallels even today that
Richard grosser by the way I should tell
you won the Pulitzer Prize
one of the first pilote surprises for
his work on this and it truly was
investigative financial journalism and
there are parallels in that even today
and let's use Enron for instance most
reporters were writing about Enron and
holding up Ken Lay and Jeff Skilling and
all of that group of men and leaders of
that company as geniuses hailing them
and no one was willing to say until
really a fairly obscure one fairly
obscure reporter was willing to say the
emperor has no clothes there is still to
this day as much as I love newspaper and
as much as I'm devoted to investigative
journalist and journalism there is still
a pack mentality that is that there's a
fear of breaking out of the pack and
being the first one to say wait a second
you have these offshore companies that
aren't really doing anything except
moving money from here to there and so I
think unfortunately some of the same
problems that afflicted the other
newspapers in town the Boston Globe the
Boston Herald the Boston Travel of the
Boston transcript and on and on
are still with us today and I think that
the lessons of Richard grosser of being
willing to really bet at all and to
stake yourself in the public interest
because he feared that the people who
the men and women the men who worked in
his press room who he knew were going
the Boston Post was located on on
Washington Street and were going around
the corner to School Street to invest
their hard-earned dollars with Ponzi he
wanted to stop them from losing money he
truly was acting in the public interest
and too often newspapers and and other
media forms of media today are afraid to
do that they they simply don't want to
devote the resources to it when I was
where the globe we had something I was a
member of the spotlight team the
investigative sort of elite
investigative reporting team and it's
incredibly expensive to maintain a
spotlight team there were often three or
three two or three editors and to me two
or three reporters in an editor and a
researcher who might write one or two
stories or series a year it's
tremendously expensive enterprise but
it's the most important kind of
reporting and so I wish more of us
follow the example of Richard grosser
than do thank you any other questions
it's really a thrill to read your book
because I'm the granddaughter ultra
gross oh my god exchanged email yes nice
to see you and I never knew him he died
many years before I was born in fact my
mother never met him either
my father was 12 when he died um so it's
really a thrill to read such a vivid
portrait and learn things that I had
never known I think that my family had
never known about him um and of course
the portrait of him is is a great one
for me it's great to think that you had
an ancestor who was so courageous but I
have maybe a little skepticism about
that I mean I'd always known that he'd
been the publisher of the post that
posted one the post had won this puled
surprise for exposing Ponzi and I'd
always assumed that that it was someone
else it was the reporters or it was and
and clearly you think he was a really
important figure since you devote so
many chapters of the book to him and
kind of fleshing out his character so
what's the evidence that led you to
think that it was that it was him in
particular that was the key player great
question um thank you and it's
delightful to meet you I should also say
The Grocer family was incredibly helpful
and I guess your aunt yeah is was cited
in the source notes as a tremendous
helper in finding out about Richard
grosser so I'm very grateful uh there
are several important pieces of evidence
that Richard grosser was truly had his
hand on the tiller at that moment and
the best piece was a piece that ran in
editor and publisher an interview with
Richard grosser and with other newspaper
men of the era
immediately after the Pulitzer was one
where the details of how the post went
after the peel the Ponzi and his scheme
we are detailed in minute detail and are
told in great detail as in terms of how
he stepped up and then it happened again
when the Pulitzer was awarded the Boston
Post of course wrote a story about it
and also detailed it almost the
day-by-day happenings of how Richard
grosser was directing done his city
editor
to stay on it to stay on it and back
then also what I do know about
newspapers and there's a wonderful book
called Park Row and there's also a great
history of that that I'm going to forget
its name of new of Boston newspaper hang
that make clear just how intimately
these editor slash publishers were
involved there is no way it's almost
inconceivable that the Boston Post would
have been able to go after Ponzi alone
for day after day the way it did without
Richard grows you're saying keep it up
there's no way that Eddie Don the city
editor could have possibly sent her
Baldwin up to Montreal to search out
Ponzi's past without approval from
Richard grosser for to pay that bill and
to go after him and finally the best
piece of evidence ultimately is when the
Pulitzer is won everyone assumes people
didn't know that Edwin Adkins grower
your great-grandfather was sick they had
kept that from the public and everyone
credited Edwin Atkins grocer with having
led the post through this episode and in
as I think I tell in the book
Edwin Atkins Crozier stands up and says
no it wasn't me it was Richard it was my
son and I mean Norma's Lee proud of him
and that to me was irrefutable evidence
that he he was driving the train
well any more questions yes two brief
questions what was the role of Clarence
Baron and Donald Dunn who wrote another
book on Ponzi is he related to the done
that you mentioned I don't believe so I
don't believe so Donald I wrote a
fictional version of Ponzi's story and
clarence baron was brought in basically
by the post to act as their financial
expert because as good as the reporters
and editors of the post were everyone
knew that Clarence Baron the great he
was a he was a huge man he they called
him the Commodore he was a giant of a
man of 300 pounds with a huge white
beard and he liked to dress in a
captain's hat and and everyone knew that
he was the most authoritative man in
America about financial dealings he ran
both ear and Barons he ran the we owned
the Wall Street Journal at this point
and he put out the Boston news Business
News and so they turned to him and they
said you know is this possible and so he
became their primary source to debunk
the possibility that you could turn
these coupons into cash and Ponzi and
Baron Ponzi understood just what a
threat Baron was to him and in the midst
of this Ponzi threatens to file a five
million dollar suit against Baron and
goes around town saying Baron owned a
huge farm and to get provided milk for
poor children in Boston and Ponzi said
in all squeeze him so dry his even his
cows won't give milk and so it was a
Ponzi and Baron also faced off and part
of the excitement I hope you can tell I
had fun writing this this is just a it's
truly a labor of love
yeah how many stories did they're right
it was it a series of obviously was a
series of stories they wrote how many
stories does it take them to I guess
prove that Ponzi was a criminal well I
don't want to it was day after day for
weeks
for several weeks it
the climax or I guess you could say the
the collapse came several weeks after
that first July 24th story
I'm each day they would write several
stories and and and then all the other
newspapers were piling on but they were
kind of hanging back they would they
clearly let the post take all the heat
and some of the other papers were in
fact rooting for Ponzi the stories that
I found in the Boston traveler in the
Boston Herald they were very much the
working man's paper they were they
wanted to believe Ponzi they wrote
incredibly flattering stories about him
and they they went out to the house and
Lexington took beautiful pictures and
showed him with his wife and you know
and and they were writing happy stories
and the post was just banging him
sometimes three and four stories a day
for several weeks and then in the
aftermath hundreds more but to answer
your question I probably 20 to 30
stories over a two to three week period
Italy well at least thirty I was gonna
sort of interested in who were the
investors in the Ponzi scheme were they
common people I mean whether the what
was the amount that was required really
to invest such that common people could
be investing in it and were there any
businessmen business people and
well-to-do people who were also taken in
by this and I have to make a point I've
been sitting here for 45 minutes
looking at you looking at the front core
the book I have to disagree with you
that cut picture of Ponzi does look just
like I thought I was going to get out
without that happening oh thank you it's
a great question it started off with
Italian immigrants just like himself he
started with one salesman a fellow named
Ettore goo Bertie and that it sort of
grew into the Italian community at first
and once that started word moves from
downstairs to upstairs the people who
would come in the brahmana's of Boston
the people from other cultures you know
as Boston's very tribal city and so it
spread from the Italian Enclave in the
north end and over to the Irish in the
south end and the Jews in the West End
and then the brahmins on Beacon Hill got
wind of it from the people who worked
for them sometimes in their stores and
their shops cleaning their houses and by
the end seventy-five percent of the
boston police force was invested with
ponzi people believed people Brahmins
were standing it was the only place in
Boston where you could see you know a
matronly lady from Beacon Hill standing
next to a black Porter waiting to invest
and and there was no limit on the money
it was I tell the story of a little boy
in short pants who was a newspaper
carrier investing a few dollars and then
there was a banker from Lawrence who put
in ten thousand dollars so by the end as
it grew it truly was an explosion of
people from all classes all races and
and we were able to learn that from the
records that I was able to obtain in the
the Massachusetts judicial archive of
every one of Ponzi's investors and then
I was able to trace back a lot of their
families and through census records to
find out exactly who they were
were they immigrants or were they
property owners thank you
I was just curious when when did this
become there did it ever become a real
big national story and how long of a
national story was it that mean did it
just spread across the country
it did near the end when all this was
happening in the summer of 1920 papers
from around the country started getting
wind of it
people were as I say he opened branches
from Maine down to New Jersey and people
were clamoring across the country the
the wire services were carrying the
stories and you can find Ponzi stories I
found Ponzi stories in Tulsa and you
know ap story is rewritten from the post
or the other papers and so it was very
much a national story by the beginning
of August 1920 and people were talking
about it literally everywhere in the
country and people were sending Ponzi
telegrams even when the post was
attacking him saying please invest my
money please take my money and literally
sending money through the mouth people
were offering can you let me open up in
Oklahoma City Bureau please I want to do
this and Ponzi thought he could use that
in a way to get out Ponzi thought his
popularity he was one of the most
popular men in America at this moment he
and you'll you'll see if you read the
book he thought he could use he could
turn that popularity into cash and he
very nearly did a no I'm sorry answer
question how long it went on it went on
really for a decade once everything was
resolved in a legal way the stories kept
appearing through court cases and trials
and and you name it and Ponzi was not
finished in Boston I will give you one
hint in mid 1920s there was a bit of a
land boom in Florida and now a lot of
this land of course was underwater which
was made it a little problem for people
who wanted to build houses on them but
and Ponzi threw his hat into that ring
too
any more questions not thank you thank
you very much